aoc was uh talking about paternity leave
and she was doing i think it's another
instagram live um or this might be might
be on tick tock i don't know
but
she has a case you were wondering um she
is also of course bought in entirely to
the idea that
that you know we can't use the word
mother
that's the that's the m word and that's
offensive and so here's her
language of choice listen
and we do tend to find that for example
um
dads because we give it to all parents
whether you are the birthing parent
adoptive parent whatever um so dads
sometimes like to take that first month
and then their spouses will um you know
uh take you know time off and then maybe
they'll try to take additional time off
after their spouse's leave is expired or
they'll take leave while their spouse is
taking leave but it's up to you
the birthing parent is what we're going
with you know birthing parent
birthing people
uh there was also something i saw uh on
twitter a couple days ago which was um
and it's not the first time i've seen
this but
the other label that you see sometimes
now is um bleeders
i mean how much more dehumanizing and
degrading can you get
and the the other funny kind of erotic
thing about this is that
um so often what they'll what you hear
from the left is that well we don't want
to define women by just their body parts
by their you know menstrual cycles by
any kind of physical function that way
because that's very limiting and
that's exactly what they do
literally defining bleeder
reducing women down just to that
or even birthing person
so while they say that i want to reduce
women to their biological functions or
to their body parts that is precisely
exactly what they do
one other thing on a similar note here
is from the new york post um
it almost incredible like it's almost
hard to believe this and i i remember i
first saw claims of this online and i
thought uh you know
really did they go that far apparently
they did so an image of controversial
transgender swimmer leah thomas that
aired on to the today show
was manipulated to make her well i'm
reading the language from the article
which says her
but it's actually him so i guess i'll
just change that was manipulated to make
him appear more feminine experts said
um
jonathan gallagher say former white
house director of digital content
president trump said the edited image
has definitely undergone some sort of
softening and smoothing effect it's
clear this job was not done by a
professional
this level of skin smoothing is a
hallmark sign of an immature job
another photographer said well that's
really bad uh so you have photographers
people who are involved in digital
editing that have said that um
that what the the today show actually
doctored an image of leah thomas
in the pool to kind of smooth his
features out a little bit more and make
him look feminine
so they're kind of
after the fact and they also says what
do they do they removed facial
they removed facial lines
skin discoloration
notable red impressions on his face
caused by goggles whatever and blurred
the adam's apple
um the show later ran the original photo
warts and all in a clip posted to
twitter on march 18th
so maybe the today show will try to
defend itself but right now they haven't
said anything about this and they
probably will
try to just ignore it but
if they do have to defend themselves
maybe they'll say this was a rogue
editor or something that did this on
their own i'd be very skeptical of that
but there was a decision made in editing
uh to try to make this guy look more
feminine look more like a woman
and of course even after the camera
tricks and the photoshop he still looks
like a man
a slightly feminized man but still a man
and they do this even though they say
that um
there's no reason why
having a
prominent adam's apple or you know
having any
traditionally male feature at all should
preclude you from being a woman
they say that and then yet after the
fact they're going to try to you know
give
give leah thomas a little bit of an
assist by feminizing him in the in the
post post edit i mean it's just uh as i
said almost almost surprising almost
that they would go that far
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content